president biden is promising tornado
victims in kentucky that the federal
government will help them rebuild
yesterday the president saw firsthand
the damaging areas that the state's
tornadoes that killed 74 people last
week the national weather service now
says one of those twisters was an ef4
the strongest december tornado ever
recorded in kentucky lilia luciano is in
dawson springs kentucky one of the
damaged towns the president visited
lilia good morning
good morning to you nate fema workers
are here on the ground helping people
sign up for aid after the tornado
destroyed three-fourths of the homes
here in dawson springs but the cost of
recovery is so high and in a town where
people make about 25 000 a year that's
the median income they fear that their
community will inevitably break apart
at 87 years old andy hernandez and his
78 year old wife betty are starting over
we love just about everything
some donations from their church and the
few things they call their own are
packed up in a truck we love that little
house and uh
but anyway it's told it's it's total
yeah it's totally the house can't be
held no now they have to leave their
home the couple couldn't afford renters
insurance and they can't afford to stay
in dawson springs we live on a limited
income and we had to come back because
we were paying 500 a month with medicare
and supplements and it went up so high
in a town of about 2 400 people nearly a
third live below the poverty line during
his visit to dawson springs wednesday
president biden promised the government
would help get people back on their feet
i promise you the governor is not
walking away your county judge is not
walking away your congress is not
walking away no one's walking away we're
in this for the long haul and across the
state dozens of families are grieving
the deaths of their loved ones like the
family of 50 year old matt ferguson who
tried to ride it out at home that part
where you see the concrete bricks over
there
that was where his trailer was according
to his sister kathy he has never left
his house no matter how bad the storm
got it'll be all right
that's how he was it'll be all right i
miss him already
and i'd wish that i had called him and
told him to get over here
but
knowing him he would never come
we've heard so many stories like that
when president biden promised the
federal government will cover 100
percent of the cost of emergency work
and recovery for 30 days but we've been
visiting shelters talking to families
and what they tell us is they fear what
lies ahead despite the assistance from
the federal government the local
communities their communities are being
displaced and they really fear the long
impact
the long-term impact of the trauma that
they and their children are facing
gail
lilly you make a very good point what
lies ahead looks very daunting right now
thank you so much